hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
lot of news leftover from the flash
arrow legends of tomorrow the big
announcements they made the other day so
this is gonna be like part Q&A part
extra video for all the new stuff the
really big news this morning is that
they just cast the female doctor light
for the flash season 2 if you don't know
the story of dr. light there's two
different characters
there's the villain dr. Arthur light who
was briefly mentioned during arrow
season 2 episode 19 and then there's the
female doctor like kimi o Hoshi who's a
medical doctor in an astronomer our
third light was the first doctor light
he turned into a serial rapist in the
comics in the last like 15 years so that
became incredibly unpopular so the TV
show is just gonna sidestep that just
you know try to avoid that hot-button
issue then because they mentioned him on
the TV show he is canon he just the way
they talk about him he was a scientist
at STAR Labs that went nuts and just
kind of ran off into the woods so my
thought is is what they might do on the
flash season two is they might use her
medical background to integrate her with
the STAR Labs people obviously they're
not gonna bring her on the show if she's
not gonna interact with the flash we're
also probably gonna get to see her get
her powers now in the comics is a little
bit different they're gonna have to
change that the way she got him in the
comics was through crisis on Infinite
Earths back during the 80s the monitor
was battling the anti-monitor
and he wanted to raise one last champion
so he sent this beam of energy down to
earth where she was observing the the
crisis the multiverse crisis go on from
a giant telescope she was working as an
astronomer and it gave her her photonic
powers think of her is like a walking
holodeck with the safety turned off so
we'll see what the show makes her powers
look like whenever we see her but
whenever she debuts she'll probably just
be a regular scientist and then she'll
get her powers usually whenever the
biggest comic book characters come on
the flash we get to see them get their
powers or at least get some tech of some
sort the way they'll probably explain it
is is that the particle accelerator
explosion last year gave her her powers
and she's still learning how to use them
at various points in the comics she was
also a researcher at STAR Labs so they
might go with that part of her backstory
she also has the ability to fly I don't
know if she's going to do that on the
show or not because Hawkgirl and Hawkman
are gonna be able to fly so we will have
a couple flying superheroes in season
two
it's just kind of hard to do flying
characters and broad daylight without
making it look really silly unless you
have like Batman V Superman level budget
following up on the cool constant teen
news Stephen Amell supposedly said that
he's gonna be around for episodes four
or five I don't think he was super
positive on which one it was gonna be
but I think episode five will be that
Sara Lance resurrection episode and I
saw a lot of confusion in the comments
because Sara is seen climbing out of the
lazarus pit in the legends of tomorrow
trailer a lot of you seem like you were
confused about how Constantine was gonna
affect that like how he was gonna help
resurrect her the way they explained it
is is that just dumping her in the pit
as she is right now wouldn't work
because she's been dead for so long so
Constantine has to like throw some extra
magic on top of the Lazarus Pit they
made it sound like they were gonna use
the Lazarus Pit and Constantine would
supercharge the process
speaking of which fantastical stuff this
is a magic base but I forgot to mention
they cast a new actress they're not
saying who she is but she looks a lot
like Carol Ferris she's gonna be part of
the coast city storyline she's gonna be
a character in present-day that had a
relationship with Oliver before he
became the arrow so we might see her in
the flashbacks but they haven't really
said but in present day she'll be in
Coast City so that's why a lot of people
are thinking that she might be Carol
Ferris Marc Guggenheim said that the
Green Lantern characters the the Green
Lantern's themselves are kind of off
limits on TV right now but that doesn't
mean that Carol Ferris is not she could
be anybody she could be an original
character to the show but if she was
they probably would have come out and
said it usually when they don't tell us
who a character is is because they're
playing somebody really major and really
critical to the plot so fingers crossed
for Carol Ferris but don't be surprised
if she is not if she's just a new person
that they created they also just cast
Tara from True Blood as a police
character that's going to be in Starling
city if you remember the vigilante task
force from season one that they put
together there's gonna be a new version
of that and she'll play a character from
the comics but she won't have super
powers she's just gonna be a normal
police officer the producers also said a
couple things about Wally West and how
he's going to be related to the other
characters they didn't come right out
and answer the question but they
throw a little bit of water on the
nephew theory so as of right now the
possibilities are that he is the earth-2
son of Joe West and Joe West did not
have a daughter on earth - or he is a
child that Joe West didn't know about
whenever they end up going with they
they did say that it would be like a big
light bulb moment like you go aha
this is actually pretty wonderful the
way they explained it so I trust them
completely with it it's not gonna be
like some silly soap opera explanation
so what I did is I I pulled a couple of
constantine related questions that you
guys had mostly constantine related
stuff just because the show's been
cancelled and you know we don't know
what's gonna happen with the character
after this one off so here we go first
question Peter asks now the constantine
is in the CW verse would that mean that
everything that happened on the NBC show
be in the arrow flash universe now no
just assume that that's like an
alternate timeline but the character
himself will be the character from the
NBC show so if you did want to get
really technical you could say that that
NBC stuff is now candid to flash and
arrow but what'll probably happen is is
they just won't talk about it that's the
easy way around problems like that just
don't mention it and let the fans
speculate if you're wondering about the
rest of the Constantine cast like the
characters they introduced like the
spectre the deal was just for Matt Ryan
only Matt Ryan is gonna come on arrow
the rest of the cast in the crew behind
Constantine have all been released
they're all working on other projects
now next question large asks with arrow
being about physical strength and
willpower flash being all about science
a third show dealing with magic would
create an interesting triangle yeah I
mean that would be cool the problem is
is that they have legends of tomorrow in
the CW can only program ten hours of
television a week that's really all they
have room for so when they bring legends
of tomorrow on for instance they'll
actually have to postpone some of their
other shows to make room for it legends
isn't going to be like a full 2223
episode run it'll be closer to like 13
they had they haven't specified the
exact number of episodes yet but if
they're having that much trouble fitting
that show into the schedule in the
spring then there's really no way that
they could fit even more shows in the
other problem with doing more DC TV
shows is that half of their programming
would turn into like DC Comics stuff it
would represent a risk from an
advertising standpoint that I don't
think that they would want
like they want to diversify their
programming as much as possible like
make all the shows feel really different
they love doing comic book shows like
they love doing all this DC stuff but
they don't want to turn into the DC
Channel next question Allen asks this
also makes Gotham the same universe I'm
not I'm not sure what you're saying that
in response to but technically Gotham is
its own thing it's loosely connected to
air on the flash because it's DC stuff
but the work around that the producers
of all the shows used to explain it is
that we're open to crossovers we just
haven't figured it out yet the fact that
Gotham is kind of set in the past puts
them in a bit of a bind so logically the
workaround to that would be time-travel
but Gotham hasn't really gotten into
like the fantastical stuff yet they
haven't done a lot of magic they're just
like a couple steps behind that so it'd
be weird if rip hunter just showed up on
Bruce Wayne's doorstep fun fact though
the actor that plays Victor Zsasz also
starred as a rogue during the flash
season one that was just a coincidence
though logically I think what they would
do is if they wanted to do any kind of
big crossover is that they would wait
till the actor that plays Bruce Wayne is
a couple years older till the Chosin
it's like fourth or fifth season and
then they can do something a little more
fantastical something involving magic
something involving time travel Gotham
is really still trying to create its
universe right now like season two is
all about introducing a whole bunch of
new comic book villains so I definitely
think they'll be more open to crazier
stuff in future seasons next question
sgf 129 asks does this make us closer to
each regan the demon or dr. fate showing
up on arrow or flash
well actually ichigan would probably
show up on that black bird show first
there's there's a couple characters they
haven't really explained what's going on
with that Teen Titans show but I would
think that some of the magic based
characters would appear there because of
Raven we are closer though dealing with
Heaven and Hell is like one step closer
to dealing with demon possession but I
think it's gonna be at least like
another season or two before we get to
the level where we're actually meeting
demons and angels but Oliver Queen demon
hunter would be a really cool season of
arrow next question Connor asks do you
think that Grodd will have a bigger part
in season 2 now that they've introduced
him or are they going to have him lay
low a bit no I think that he'll have a
bigger part but the way we see them will
be
a little bit different so if you
remember in season one he was actually
mentioned or seen in at least like four
or five episodes I think when they bring
him back on it'll be in fewer episodes
like a fewer in number but his presence
in those episodes will be much bigger
it'll be much closer to what we saw in
episode 21 and they haven't done so
Lavar yet so they could introduce so
levar next question simple Kiros asks
will the Vixen series be the typical
animated series link or will it be 42
minutes you're asking like will it be a
half hour show or a full hour show I
think it'll be half hour but I haven't
heard specifically it's just that most
animated DC shows are only half hour
long so that's why I think that vixen is
probably just a half hour show they're
only doing six episodes is really just
to do the origin story for the character
and introduce us to the idea of magic in
the arrow and flash universe I'm really
excited it is an awesome time to be
watching DC's TV shows even the ones
that aren't on the CW like Gotham really
the biggest things in my mind are Carol
Ferris on arrow like what do you guys
think about that do you think that they
could do Carol Ferris but not do the
Green Lantern's it does sound like
something that they might be able to do
but there really isn't any confirmation
on that DC is really weird about the
characters they let them do in the ones
that they don't let them do if you ever
wondered how they figure out which
characters they're allowed to do Geoff
Johns is actually the person that helps
them out with that he'll say hey this
characters available this character is
not available so whenever they're
pitching ideas for new seasons Geoff
Johns usually sits in the writers room
or he gets on the phone with them and
answers questions about specific
characters part of his job is to keep
track of all the movies and all the TV
shows and development and all the
characters that they're using so we are
now within two weeks of vixen and within
about six weeks of air on the flash
starting so everybody just start to get
hype it's gonna be a lot of fun and for
those asking yes I am gonna do heroes
reborn videos it's gonna be a Thursday
show and since I don't have any other
Thursday shows there's nothing keeping
me from doing videos for it so I'm
actually pretty excited about that be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm probably gonna start doing some
Walking Dead stuff on Sundays along with
my Game of Thrones bonus videos so start
getting ready for Walking Dead stuff too
there were some black panther pictures
from yesterday from the set of Captain
America Civil War so I might do a new
black panther video next just in case
you guys haven't seen them I've done a
videos for flash season 2 characters you
can click here to watch all those it'll
just open my playlist with all the bonus
videos in it and you can click here for
my top 10 favorite spider-man outfits
from the comics just because they're
there been a lot of talk about his Civil
War costume thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight